B, how you doing? Hello. Hello. I'm
doing fine. I am Muslim. Yes, I'm pretty
good. Thank you for asking. You believe
that Islam is reliable? I do think so.
Yes. Do you believe that a religion that
has corrupted scripture is reliable? No.
Okay. Is the Torah in Islamic scripture?
Islamic as in submission to God, right?
Yeah. Part of that religion. Is the Is
the Torah? I would say so. Yes. Yeah. Is
the Torah is an Islamic scripture? Yes.
Okay. Was the Torah corrupted when it
was put into writing? I would say that
by that time a lot of things would have
differed from the original message. So
is that a yes? The Torah? Yes. Correct.
Okay. What about the NGL? Is the angel
in Islamic scripture? I mean Christians
do submit to God. So I would say so.
Yes. All right. So the the NGL the
gospel is an Islamic scripture. Was that
corrupted? The the what again? I'm
sorry. The gospel. The inje Yes. It was
corrupted. Okay. What about the zabor
the psalms? Mhm. Was that corrupted?
Yes. All right. And that's an Islamic
script scripture. Yes. All three of
them. All three of them. Okay. So, we
have the Torah, the Zabore, the Psalms.
Mhm. And the Injil, the Gospel. Yes. All
three of these scriptures are Islamic
scriptures. And these Islamic scriptures
got corrupted. Yes. So therefore, Islam
is unreliable because it has corrupted
texts. I would say the religion is
unreliable, right? But the word of God
is reliable, right? But humans are not.
So So Islam, Islam is unreliable. God is
reliable. Yes. Okay. So first of all,
how long have you been? I'm going to let
you go, but how long have you been how
long have you been a Muslim? Well, I was
born into a a Muslim family in a Muslim
country, right? But I've never been
religious. Okay. I never bothered with
the religion. Right. Yeah. I'm 22 now.
Okay. And eventually like when I when I
got like to 21 or 22, I would say, I
started like looking for religion,
right? I started researching. I I looked
I looked at what I had closest to me,
right, which was Islam, right? Mhm. And
then when I started reading into it, I
found out that the religion that
everyone around me was was preaching did
not make sense to me. Right?
There was a lot of like things that that
to me did not feel like God, right? I
would say hadith for example. I'm a
Quran only Muslim. Okay. Like like the
brother before me. Yeah. And um the the
same logic that Muslims apply to the
gospel saying that the original message
was divine and it was right but it it no
longer is. Why shouldn't we apply that
to hadith as well? Right. That's true.
Right. Or even the Quran. Why can't we
apply that to the Quran too? I will get
to that. Right. So I was researching the
Quran and one of the beliefs that that
we have is that the Quran was originally
word of mouth. Right? Like all the
scripture all the scriptures were
originally word of mouth. Right. And
then can you like can you open the
Quran? Right. And go to surah al bakar
verse 43. 42. 43. 43. Okay. Got it. You
there with me? Right. Yeah. Mhm. So in
here it says established player pay arms
tax and bow down with those who bow
down. Right. M now if you open like the
the narration and you hear someone
saying this verse out loud they're going
to say
so basically all of these things are
written or said in singular form but
they're written in plural form. M.
So this does not make sense to me,
right? If this was a book with an oral
tradition. Mhm. Then why does the
writing differ there? That's why I
personally think that the Quran could
not be oral tradition. I see. So you
think that it originally right off the
bat was written? Matter of fact, wait,
do you do you think that the Quran came
down like as an actual book from from
heaven? No, no. I think that it was
meant to be a book, right? Uh if you if
you see in the Quran, many times it is
addressed as a book, right? When the
Quran talks about the Quran itself, it
is a book, right? And one of one of the
one of the one of the verses that that
like of God speaking to Muhammad, he
tells him to read. That's true. He tells
him to read. It wouldn't make sense for
him to tell him to read if one he
couldn't read and two had nothing to
read, right? I do not think that the
prophet could not read either. Yeah. I
think that he could read, he could
write, he could do a lot of things.
Yeah. I mean there I mean even there's
even hadith where Muhammad asks for a
pen and paper so he can write a letter.
Yes. Apparently they didn't let him.
Yeah. Okay. Interesting. So So when you
when it says like the unlettered prophet
or something like that, you understand
that to be maybe like um just maybe
ignorant of certain scriptures or
something like that? maybe just like
unlearned. Um I mean the word um umi
right is the word they use to say that
it was unlettered. You're going to see
that it's it's I think mentioned twice
in the Quran and the translation differs
a lot according to which chapter you
read. One is unlettered and the other
one is a gentile. Interesting, right? So
it could just simply just mean gentile.
I think it means gentile. Not
necessarily that he was illiterate. He
was unlet like illiterate and
unlettered, right? In the in in the
sense of like divinity and and and
guidance from God. Yeah. He was ignorant
of God. He was ignorant of God. Yes.
Yeah. Yeah. That that that sounds pretty
that sounds legit to me. I have no qualm
against that. So So with your position,
um you're saying that, you know, uh
originally the Quran was not an oral
tradition, but a written one. And some
evidences of that is when the person or
the the angel comes to Muhammad, he
tells him to read. You know, he's not
going to tell him to read if there's
nothing to read or if he can't read.
Yes. I mean, I I think that there was no
book at the start. Obviously, he he told
people to write it or he wrote it,
right? Eventually to make sure that the
the scripture does not get corrupted.
Yeah. And obviously like the Quran
itself is not corrupted, right? But the
religion is I'm on there with you 100%.
The religion is corrupted. Okay. Like
you said earlier when I I shouldn't
trust I shouldn't trust Islam at all.
You're free to do that. In my opinion
right nowadays I would rather someone be
Christian than be a hardcore believing
Muslim because if you are a hardcore
believing Muslim then you're going to
fall into the hadith and everything.
Yeah. And I think at that at that point,
you start straying from God and you
start going onto another like different
path. Even in the Quran, it tells
Christians to follow their gospels.
That's true. And so when I when I But
here's the problem though. When I do
follow the gospel, I find that Jesus is
the son of God who gave his life for me
and died for my sins and rose in
authority on the third day. That's what
I And you're free to do that. There is
not a problem. But if I believe that,
I'll be blaspheming against Allah. Are
we talking about shik right? Yeah. Okay.
So one thing about that a shik mah so
shik with god is not the same as shik
bah which is the main problem in
religion would be terrorism. I yeah I
don't I don't mean to cut you off but
because you you are giving wisdom right
now but um I'm I'm specifically just
simply talking about the theological
issues that the Quran raises and
emphatically rejects. Right? While the
Quran I'm sorry the the Gospel when I
read it
affirms those things that the Quran
emphatically rejects. You know what I'm
saying? And and that's where we differ,
right? No, it's not where we differ. You
believe that, too. I mean, you believe
that that Jesus was the son of God,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Cuz the gospel says
that. Yes. Cuz the gospel says that and
you believe in your gospel. That's why
you're Christian. I believe in the
Quran. And so that's why I'm Muslim,
right? But how can I believe? Look, cuz
the Cuz the Quran doesn't just tell me
to believe in just my gospel. It tells
me to believe in the Quran, too. But how
how can I believe in both if the Quran
is contradicting the gospel and I'm
supposed to judge by the gospel? I mean,
it tells you it tells you to follow the
Quran obviously, right? But you do have
free will. Tells me to follow the
gospel. I mean, no, I'm we're talking
about the Quran. The Quran tells you to
follow the Quran. Me? Yes. You as a
Christian? No, no, no. Me as a
Christian, it tells me to follow the
gospel. But but if you wanted to like it
would be preferable to you or to God for
you to read the Quran and be a Muslim,
right? No. Well, well, I I think I think
that if I was a good Christian from the
Quranic standpoint, I would be a Muslim.
If I followed my scripture correctly, I
would be a Muslim. Yes. I I think so as
well. Yes. Right. But um my my my issue
is my dilemma is this is that the Quran
as you said, it confirms the Bible or
and confirms the gospel specifically and
tells me to judge by the gospel. That's
how I have to make my judgments. I have
to judge what what is true and false,
what is lawful for me or what? No,
what's not by the gospel. If I do that,
I I have to judge that the Quran is
false because the Quran contradicts the
gospel. Mhm. You see the the position
I'm in? Okay. And and let's say you do
that, right? And you do you say the
Quran is false and it is the work of of
a demon of of of a man, what whatever we
say, right? M and you do go on in your
path being a good Christian. Yeah. Do
you think that on the day of judgment if
turns out the Quran is true and it was a
revelation from God? Do you think you
would go to hell? Yeah. I I go to hell
because it says Allah says that those
who say that Jesus is the son of Allah
that Allah's curse is upon them and
we're deluded from the truth. I can't be
cursed and go to heaven, could I? But it
also says in the same book that he is
most merciful and that he will judge the
the Christians, the Jews and the rest
with with with what was revealed to
them. Right. Yes. And I according to
what is revealed to me, I have to follow
the gospel and also I have to believe in
the Quran too. I have to believe in
both. Even though I judge by my gospel,
I have to believe in all the scriptures.
I can't reject any of them. Would you
say that the message of the Quran and
the Bible is more or less the same when
it comes to being a good human and and
acting a certain way? Nope. I'd say
they're almost completely opposite. Do
do you not think that the Quran promotes
like virtuous uh actions or behaviors? I
would say that there are some surface
level things on the surface. The Quran
does have some surface level, you know,
common good morals that you would see
most religions teach, but I would say
for the most part, the Quran teaches um
heinous virtues. Heinous virtues. That
does not make any sense. Immoral immoral
behavior. Immoral behavior. Can Can you
give me an example? Okay. So, like for
example, um it said like so it talks
about the women that you're allowed to
have, right? um and talks about the
women you're not allowed to be with your
mother, sisters and all this kind of
stuff, right? Right. Those are good
things, married women. But then it says
it gives an exception to married women
that I we are allowed to have relations
with married women um who is a
right-hand possession. And so,
right.
And so this is uh an instance where
there is an exception to committing
adultery, sleeping with someone else's
wife, someone who's married. That's uh
424. You already 424. Can we get the
verse? Guys, he follows the Quran alone.
So bringing up suckling won't that's
hadith. He doesn't Yeah, I know.
suckling the breast won't have to deal
with that as well. So, thank you for
bringing up this verse, right? I
remember this this this was one of the
one of the problems that I had at the
start as well, right? Well, let's say I
still struggle with it, right? Because
in in in one place it says to free
slaves, free captives and etc. And then
here it says, "Oh, you can take a slave
if you wanted to. You could take a woman
as your possession." Right. Yeah. But
not not just that, you can have her like
sexually. Yeah. and she's married. Well,
I I looked into it, right? And um I saw
a person on YouTube and an Egyptian man,
he's he's now dead. May God rest his
soul. Well, he basically said that this
verse,
right, is basically someone you
basically have like um an agreement
with. So this this person is married,
bro. Yeah. It's it goes away from from
from being like slaves and everything to
being like, you know, like an agreement
between two people willingly, right?
That's not what a right-hand possession
is though. But like no one goes into it.
There is no explanation for like
right-hand possession. Yeah. A
right-hand possession is a captive
woman, one who you uh acquired through
war and pillaging. I see. I still have
to read up on that. Thank you for
bringing that up. Of course. Is there
anything else? There's a few other
things, you know, but uh if you have the
time, I would like to go through them.
Oh, you want to? Yes, we learn new
things. Okay. Shoot. So, you're talking
about just morality. Um there is a verse
that talks about um and I don't remember
this one off the top of my head, but I
remember the context. The context is of
the verse is that um when you divorce a
woman um in order for her to come back
to you, she has to go and sleep with
someone else and then after she slept
with that person, she can then come back
to you. And that is just obviously sick.
Do you know what I'm talking about? Hold
on. Let me Guys, what's that? What's
that verse? I think it is two 230. Let's
see. Let's see. I I know it's chapter 2.
230. If a husband Yes. 230. So if a
husband divorce his wife three times
then it is not lawful for him to remarry
her until after she has married another
man and then divorce then it is p
permissible for them to reunite as long
as they feel they are able to maintain
the limits of Allah. These are the
limits set which he makes clear for
people of knowledge. Yeah. And so this
is uh this is even something that the
Torah talks about and God calls this an
abomination like you just trading off
the girl, sharing the girl um and that
she she can't get back with her
ex-husband until she marries someone
else and sleeps with him and then they
divorce and then then she can come back
to you. That's crazy. I mean in this
verse, right, we could say it's not
talking about like sharing like for
example, let's say you marry you marry
your your wife, right? Then you have
disagreements and you know you end up
divorcing a couple of times right then
for she has to look for something else
right cuz it is obviously not working
right and if she goes and marries
another man and it doesn't work out with
them as well then you can technically
marry her right but I'm sure that some
people probably have you know use this
to just [__] like I'm sorry for swearing
yeah it's okay just just be careful yeah
yeah I'm sorry just to like ended up
sharing ing, you know, wives using this
verse. I mean, it does say which she
makes clear for people of knowledge,
right? Which I'm sure back then it
wasn't it wasn't a common thing to have
people of knowledge. the the the whether
it's a common thing or not, you have
Allah who's giving a command on when
when you divorce your wife, divorce her,
she cannot come back to you until she
has married with someone else, you know,
and obviously it has to be consummated
and then boom. Um then she can come back
to you. That's why. But but I mean,
yeah, I agree with you. If that was the
case, right? Isn't that what it says?
Ain't that what it says? That she can't
come back to him. She can't get back
with her husband until she marries
someone else and then divorce. They get
divorced and then she can come back to
him. Right? Let me let me read the verse
again a second, please. It's a handsome
gentleman. That's not what I wanted to
share. after he has divorced her, then
she is not lawful unto him unto him
thereafter until she has married another
husband, then if the other husband
divorces her, it is no sin on both of
them that they reunite, provided they
feel that they can keep the limits
ordained by Allah. These are the limits
of Allah, which he makes plain for the
people who have knowledge. Okay. Wait,
I'm sorry. I'm I'm I'm new to this uh to
this channel. You said your name was
Avery. Am I pronouncing that correctly?
Okay, that's right. So, I think in my
opinion, if the wife, you know, in this
situation goes and marries another man
for the sole objective of getting back
with that with that with the original
husband, I think then like that is a sin
up. That is what you called an
abomination earlier on. Wait, what you
said? You said what if the what what's
the condition? Like if if the woman like
her entire point of marrying that other
husband, right? Mhm. Was just so she
could divorce him and then come back to
her original husband, then that is an
abomination. I agree with you 100% on
that. So you're talking about intention.
Intention. Yes. It matters a lot. Yeah.
It's it's not about the intention. It's
simply about the action. the action of
getting divorced, going and marrying and
sleeping with someone else and then
going back to your ex-husband. That
right there, like that condition, why
put that condition on that? Why does she
have to go marry and sleep with someone
else before she can get with her husband
again, her real husband? I mean, if if
if we read the Quran in in in its
entirety, right? I don't I don't think
that that is behavior that that that God
would want you to, you know, act like
that like is what he commands. That is
not what he commands. I think he says he
puts I am I am I am no expert and then
again I am not God right. I cannot speak
for him. I can just speak like from from
what I can I can see and and and what I
think right. Sure. In this verse I think
that intention matters a lot like you
said. So you're saying that it's okay.
This regulation is a is a moral
regulation. Let's say she doesn't she's
not it's it's not oh um let me get
married and have sex so that I can get
back with my husband. That's just simply
this regulation is is morally okay to
you. Yeah. Just so people don't keep
just getting married and divorcing
getting married and divorcing getting
married and divorcing because eventually
it's just going to you know end up bad
and maybe just cancel out divorce period
then right cancel out divorce no
divorcing. Yeah. just say no divorcing.
I think divorcing is necessary
sometimes. You know, sometimes. Yeah.
So, under under circumstances, you know,
divorce, but just outside of these like
extreme circumstances, divorce should be
not allowed. Yeah, I I agree with you as
well. Okay. Do you want to see one more?
Yeah, sure. If you have time, of course.
One more and then this is it. So, um I'm
pretty sure you're probably familiar
with this is the biggest one that
everyone brings up obviously is
um uh child relations. Child relations.
This is a new one. I have I haven't You
haven't heard this accusation against
Islam for real? Well, I don't really
like go up and and and hear debates and
stuff like this is my first time because
I'm curious about Yes. I'm curious about
religion. I recently started reading
John. Okay. Interesting, man. All right.
So, the verse is chapter 65 verse4.
65 verse4. This is my least favorite
topic, by the way. But I don't mind
sharing people why I reject Islam. Guys,
we got over 3,000 people watching and we
don't even have 2,000 likes yet. I'm
watching it right now. It looks like we
got 1,700 likes. What's going on here?
Let's get the likes up, y'all. Come on.
Let's get the likes up to 2500K. 2500K.
2500. 2500 likes. That's what she Every
single person should be smashing that
like button right now. Share the live,
guys. Come on. Don't out yourselves,
man. Don't do it. Don't do it to
yourself. We know what you secretly do
if you're not hitting that like button.
Y'all know the drill. Okay. So, I'm I'm
on the verge. As for your women past the
age of menstruation, in case you do not
know, their waiting period is 3 months.
And those who have not menstruated as
well. As for those who are pregnant,
their waiting period ends with delivery.
And whoever is mindful of Allah, he will
make their matters easy for them.
So the issue that I have here, well,
let's just like talk about what the
verse is talking about. This talking
about divorce, right? And the waiting
period that women have that's required
for them before they move on to the
next, you know, person. And so it's
three months, right? Their waiting
period is three months. That's the IDA,
the waiting period. Now, there's three
categories except for the pregnant
woman. So, there's three categories of
women, three categories of females that
it's addressing. Obviously, the old one
who's past the age of ministration,
right? They don't minrate anymore. Um,
and so they're it waiting period is 3
months before they can move on to make
sure they're not pregnant. Mhm. The
second category are the ones who have
not ministrated. And you you uh you you
speak Arabic? I do speak Arabic. Yes.
What what is it there? What is the word
there? Um, for those who do not
ministrate, let me go back to the verse.
Should say something like lama, right?
Lamna. Yes. And what? And that means
like it never happened in the past. Like
they have not menrated at all yet,
right? Yes. They're technically
children. Yes. Yes. Technically
children. So you have the older women
who are being divorced. You have the
children who are being divorced. You
have the pregnant women who are being
divorced. My problem is obviously
category number two that children are
being married and divorced and they're
still even there are still kids while
they're being divorced. Yes. Now here's
another layer to it because some might
argue that oh well you know it's just
maybe you know a marriage contract is
drawn up right like you know it's not
consummated maybe they're engag maybe
they're married and there's a married
contract but they no nothing happened.
They there was no relations there,
right? However, here's the key point.
The key point is that these children,
they have an ida, a waiting period,
right? Yes. You according to the Quran,
you only have an ida if the marriage was
consummated, if the husband touched you.
And this said, this is in chapter 33 49.
So, if we look at chapter 33:49 real
quick, uh I'll pull it up too. Okay, it
says, "Oh, you who believe when you
marry believing women and then divorce
them before you have sexual intercourse
with them, no have you to count in
respect of them." So give them a present
and set them free. Right. So if you
haven't touched her, if you guys had not
have had intercourse, noda, there is no
waiting period. Yeah. Yeah. I see your
point. I see your point.
So in 654 it shows not just that the
girls were getting married and divorced,
but that their husbands were sleeping
with them and their kids, their
children. So that that right there I
could I could never that's just that's
evil and sick. There's I there's no
defense of this. That's a problem. Well,
I mean I do agree with you that that
that is a very big problem, right? But I
would say that back then the people of
at that time Arabia right they they you
know they didn't have that many morals I
would say right it was it was a
free-for-all basically right and I would
say that this verse is descriptive right
like that was the case back then right
people were marrying children right so
if you if you brought down a like a
revelation right to guide those people
that would apply to them as well right
the revelation to those people would
Leave those kids alone. Stop sleeping
with them. Stop marrying them. Right?
Not regulating sexual relationship with
kids. It does tell you to to wait till
till someone is is like till someone
menstruate before you marry them in
another Quran. The Quran nowhere says
that. Let me look for the verse. I might
be wrong though. But this let me see.
Yeah. Unfortunately, the Quran doesn't
say that anywhere. Uh chapter 4 verse
six. Verse six. Yes. It's about the
orphan. It's about an orphan and before
you give her her things, her
inheritance, she has to be of
marriageable age, she has to be older
and mature. That's completely different
from just believing women, believing
females, just getting married, period.
Two different contexts. Well, thank you
for bringing that up. That that was
definitely interesting. I'm going to
have to look into that. 100%, bro. 100%.
Well, thank you for having me, uh,
Avery. Yeah, that was a pleasant talk.
Yeah, for sure. It was very good. I
enjoyed it. You too, man. Come back
anytime, man. Yeah, sure, dude. Thank
you. All right. Peace. All right. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Guys, there's there's
there's no defending uh there's no
defending Islam, man. There's no
defending Islam. And I think that if you
are an honest person, if you are an
honest person, you would leave Islam
immediately. Once you've seen this and
once you've looked at it, there's no way
that you could be a Muslim. No way. In
order to be a Muslim, you have to
suppress the truth and unrighteousness.
You have to you have to water it down.
Water the Quran down. Water Islam down
in order to keep hold to it. Just as
Romans 1 says that they suppress the
truth and
unrighteousness. All right. The
alternative is this. The alternative is
you turn you turn to the Lord who while
you were still a sinner, while you were
deceived and in darkness, still gave his
life up for you. and promises to drag
you out of the darkness to be your light
and to make you a light as well. Salt of
the earth, turn to the Lord who no one
can accuse of any wrong, no one can
accuse of any evil, no one can accuse of
any sin, any immorality, perfect and
holy and just. You don't have to defend
him. His own righteousness speaks for
itself. His act of love speaks for
itself. Turn to him. You don't have to
defend something like Allah. You don't
have to defend the actions of something
like Muhammad. Run to the Lord Jesus
Christ and you will be like, "Man, I
can't
believe I can't believe I thought
otherwise. I served another." He says
that his burden is easy and his yoke is
light. Come to him. He'll give you rest
for your soul. You won't have to stress
out trying to defend Jesus. You won't.
There's a guarantee. I guarantee.